like i i completely forgot about
japanese arcades as well oh my god
we even spoke about that yeah we haven't
spoken about that my second home baby
i'm not in an arcade i was at an arcade
just yesterday actually because i i
wanted to get uh what's that piano game
that you and i are really into it's like
nos not nostalgia i think it's called
things i think it's something like that
basically
in japanese japanese arcades are [ __ ]
next level yeah like like it's
like rk's just didn't die here and
there's so many cool things about
japanese arcades that you just can't get
anywhere else in the world if you think
american arcades are fun you will not
in a japanese yeah yeah exactly it's a
different experience from arcade because
growing up my arcade experience is
always like kind of like
you know uh house of the dead those type
of people yeah yeah like party games
yeah time crisis right that's like and
they do have those i'd say those are the
only games that really translated
well from like western arcades like
dance revolution as well
i don't know because like uh japanese
arcades have so many rhythm games
it's like 80 rhythm games but they've
got so many unique ideas about whether
games because i remember when i was like
when before i came to a japanese arcade
i was like oh yeah rhythm games aren't
really my thing you know i didn't really
enjoy ddr
all that kind of stuff and then i went
to a japanese arcade and there are just
so many different types of rhythm games
and it's [ __ ] crazy
i mean i thought i thought after you
know playing guitar hero and just
pretending to be a band or
what was it rock band rock band playing
basically every instrument i was like
rhythm games aren't going to get better
than this because you're pretending to
be play the instruments yeah and then
japanese okay to be like now how about
we just
invent instruments yeah you see you see
this dj
board right here yeah six buttons you're
a dj now
and it feels amazing when you like turn
the knobs and stuff like that yeah
oh okay i'm making some music right now
goddamn
yeah but no i was the exact same like
i've always liked rhythm games yeah
before you know like rhythm heaven and
stuff like that on the ds like i played
[ __ ] out of those games
loved it um but when i moved here
i was the exact same right i was like
i'm not a huge fan of ddr
you never really played a lot of rhythm
games like in western arcades and i
didn't really
even have an arcade in australia yeah we
didn't do we didn't really have an
arcade that was nearby enough like we
had one in the city
yeah there's one that was really far
away from me yeah but like the city for
me where i live is like
45 minute driving oh [ __ ] so to a 14
year old it might as well be in a
different country yeah yeah yeah
so my only experience with arcades is
the japanese arcades
yeah but even when i was little i would
go to a japanese arcade and i never
really touched the rhythm games because
yeah all these like high school kids are
around and as a 10 year old you don't
want to go into that crowd
those dudes on the on some of these
games are insane you know you know
someone is like insane when
there's like a 16 year old just rocking
up in front of a tube
tuning the machine and he just puts his
gloves on the gloves if they wear gloves
they're like
serious yeah it's like the anime moment
you know whatever you put on the glove
it's like on the gloves he just does the
the shine
and he just gets wrecked like he they
just stretches and [ __ ] i'm just like
is it that the game where they go like
this yeah yeah yeah they for some reason
i don't know why all the good players do
it there must be a trick that but they
all throw their hands in the air when
they're playing i think i think
i've played tuna before that's an actual
movement
what did you say don't worry about it
i'm going to see the replay no but like
i played two near them once because i
was also
just like that's an actual movement you
need to do you have to
there's a sensor in the actual board
that senses your hands moving
up yeah yeah yeah but a lot of them do
it like when they've you know in the
movies
or they finish their piano solo and they
just like raise their hand yeah yeah
they go
high yeah it looks like it looks like
you know a classical pianist
just finishing their performance right
but they're doing it
every time i mean i mean like they're
almost putting in as many inputs as like
a japanese pianist like
a professional pianist sometimes it's it
looks so cool though
when someone's good you're like man this
this is this is amazing this is like a
spectator sport right here yeah
but then you think about man how many
100 yen coins did they have to go
through
to get to that level you get like three
songs most of the time so about 10
minutes for about
100 yen which is yeah less than a dollar
so wait so what are the go-to rhythm
games for you guys at an rk
um i like the one you showed me i can't
remember it was cool but
it's one way it's like a massive circle
oh yeah
yeah yeah and basically it's it's it's a
really unique input
input where it's like the entire circle
and you have to like follow the lines
and everything like that we'll have a
video on screen
yeah yeah it's it was something that
it's written games like this that you
just can't i
i've just never seen before my fingers
though
it was the first time i considered i was
like should i buy glasses
because it's like a plastic thing right
and some of the inputs are like do a
full 360 with your hand so you're just
sliding your sweaty palms all around
this thing and you're like
trying to get your hand right i was like
oh that's where the gloves come in here
no because because the thing is sand
they're not buttons as well they're all
just senses so you're just here like
smashing this smashing this hard surface
like
dude and it just it hurts your fingers
oh my god [ __ ] hurt
hurts i love the like the piano one but
that's because it's basically
what's the other piano one with the guys
do the thing in the air what's it called
uh tuna them
that i feel like that's the hard version
and the one that i like is the easy one
because
yeah it's like a piano thing but you
don't have to actually hit the right
just just close something that's close
it's
somewhere so you just so you basically
look at the screen you just do it's
really like
beginner friendly and i really like it
because a lot of them like there's i
feel
the problem with a lot of the the games
is there's medium
and then there's [ __ ] insane like
there's there's no in between
and i always had this problem with
guitar hero yeah where like i could do
medium fine
but when we put the little pinky
involved that's when it all fell apart
like
i couldn't do it but it makes you feel
like a piano oh my god
shut the [ __ ] up or all the classic the
uh the taiko drums right oh yeah
yeah that's that that's like whenever
you bring someone you're like get up
yeah come on you'll enjoy this it's so
easy to understand right it's like
monkey brain mode
i hit two places okay i understand yeah
what about you uh i mean
the one i always go to is a groove
coaster oh you always play rooftop it
looks cool though groove coast is fun
which one's that one groove coaster is
the one with the giant it's like pure
adhd and there's
two like bulbs that you have to like
move around and tap yeah i
sucked at it at first but then i went to
this con in uh washington dc like
two years ago maybe three years ago
right and they had a groove coaster
machine but no one was in front of it
and at this point i'd never played
groove coaster before yeah
and i just saw this groove coaster
machine that nobody was lining up in
front of
and it was free to play yeah yeah and
the cons the whole car yeah yeah yeah
so i was like i've got like two hours to
kill [ __ ] it and no one's lighting up in
front of this thing let's do it and i
got
so good in those two hours where i was
just like he's like i have to go to jail
i have to come back to japan
and like actually get on these machines
yeah and then ever since then
i've loved it and there's also uh what's
that what's the other one what's the
cube one
keep getting oh the one where you like
tap the things yeah you have the things
in time
that's cool that one's really old
everywhere yeah yeah that's like a
classic driven game
in the japanese yeah because i remember
my first experience with like japanese
arcade games it was
there's always that fear where you're
just like i have no idea what i'm doing
you know what i mean like especially at
conventions when there's always
that guy yeah that guy who just like and
he's always before you as well
comes up with he comes with the excel
spreadsheet on the best technique
it's like all right i just wanted to
play the game but yeah yeah and you're
just you're just standing there being
like
what buttons do i press like i don't
even know any of these songs it's time
crisis
yeah and it's always like it's always
the worst incontinence as well because
you know there's people standing around
you oh no
judging you so hard it's like look at
this if you're like a guest there
everyone's gonna look at you you're like
wow
he's kind of sucks at that yeah i'm
definitely going to bring this up with
their panel later
you sucked at ddr do you have any
comments about that
sucker but that's what i love about like
japanese arcades is that you can just
spend
you can just lose so many hours in there
and it's it's really easy
because it's oh and you get the cards
yeah i was going to talk about
sorry like basically actually you you
explained joe because you're the one who
did it for me so you probably know the
process better than me
so different machines are owned by
i guess different rhythm game companies
or whatever yeah yeah and
you can if you get so good at it you can
uh buy these cards for like 300 yen
which is nothing it's like three dollars
um and you print them out and you can
save your progress on it because it's a
it's a public
rhythm game so if you just put the money
in you're treated as a guest
so your records for whatever
yeah yeah high scores that kind of stuff
doesn't get saved because you're just a
guest
so if you get so invested in a
particular rhythm game or a number of
rhythm games
you can buy these cards um and to you
know save your records and stuff like
that and you can
a lot of japanese people i know like
share it online to yeah
yeah and like i recommend getting it
anyway because there are some rhythm
games like the piano one
that if you don't have a card they're
going to make you sit through the
tutorial
and there's no way to skip it exactly
like i remember i i i really enjoyed it
and i went to
i went to the arcade on three separate
occasions and for the first like
three minutes i was just sitting there
being like remember i finished on my
first two songs i'm like you know the
tutorial yet oh
i was still doing the tutorial every
time so i was like i gotta get [ __ ]
card i need a card yeah
and the good thing is as well with those
cards is that not only the cheap but
a lot of the cards the first game that
you do
with the card is usually free so you
actually make that money back yeah yeah
yeah
so like the with groove coaster at least
when you get uh it's called a nesca card
because yeah there's nesca
and then there's a few other ones yeah
then there's the bandai one and so
i have that yeah so with the nesca card
at least when you the first game of
groove coaster you play
it's free because you just put that
money into the card
right which is which i think is a nice
compromise because it doesn't feel like
you just you know you're paying extra to
save your progress essentially and you
can you like you'll only have a set
amount of stages as a guest
yeah and if you you know level up you
learn more stages
yeah yeah exactly it's just it's just
cool to like go back to an arcade you
know every
so often just like your favorite anime
yeah yeah i got to triple s this stage
man i just have to i
have to invest they have undertale on
groove coaster right yeah they're the
entire soundtrack
i'm [ __ ] yeah dude i can do level 12
megalovania like triple s
i was pretty proud of myself cool
because the uh on groove coaster they
have like
special animations just for the
undertale song so oh really it looks
like an undertale game playing out
that's every even all the vocaloid stuff
as well they use like the music videos
for it and that's what i love about
groove coaster because every stage
actually looks really unique as well
because it has to match the song
have you tried using your card the ones
in america have you ever tried that no
i should try that that's just that that
would be pretty because it works if
you're at a convention and you just
you just probably wouldn't right because
whip out the card right yeah probably
need to be connected to the internet
i gotta i gotta flex on these people
that are triple s megalovania
level 12 you know oh you don't have all
the stages oh